there's a lot of chicks that aren't
going to stop doing what they're doing
but they still want to they're a woman
they still want affection they still
yearn for partner nobody wants to be
alone the biggest baddest [__]
that'll sit there and say oh I'm
independent I'm about just want somebody
[__] is going to want something
yeah some sort of affection some sort of
yeah or friendship something some type
of a situationship relationship doesn't
matter they're gonna want it because in
this in this world nobody's built to be
alone
um that's how I feel nobody to be alone
and I think everybody knows that deep
down inside they just can't find the
[__] words
you know what I'm saying because that's
when it really just stems to to me
everybody one and everybody wants to be
wanted not needed so you're saying
essentially essentially
companionship
but it's also obviously a business
relationship I mean when you're in that
wouldn't you want some type of
compensation